[Applause]
well Hong Kong become an issue for the
Democratic presidential hopefuls well
already is yeah yeah it's the it's the
one piece of China policy where they can
actually be tougher than the president
because the president doesn't give a
[ __ ] about human rights which is why he
hasn't talked about the mass
incarceration of wigger Muslims in in
China and which is why he's acting like
she is gonna be able to just magically
fix this problem you know so yeah it
presents an opportunity for Democrats to
reach out to the community of Americans
who aren't really pissed about China
without you know without trying to
compete with Trump on his stuff when
you've got a trade war going though
Nancy Pelosi recent always made this a
huge issue human rights in China I would
totally expect them to really emphasize
this and try and you know put Trump in a
corner on it shows that he's weak Carl
would any gun control legislation
survive the Republican majority on the
Supreme Court that's that's a great
point well that is a really really they
can pass all the legislation they want
which is tuft and a canyon with but then
well right senator Whitehouse who you
had on earlier a brief in the court this
week basically telling them to stay away
from the gun control issue because the
Republican nominees on the Supreme Court
were carefully screened for their strong
Second Amendment positions and
Republicans have blocked other
Democratic judges because of this so I'm
not sure it would survive you know the
famous Scalia decision is the law of the
land and I'll make a way to get there I
would argue it weakens black Democratic
state run kid people who are looking to
run for statewide seats oh I would what
does where I'll bet that that pushing
the second amendment line in the deep
south push my second amendment line in
the deep south not only will turn out
more Republican voter base from the
white worker class and write rule class
you begin to keep black working class
people and men in particular at home
because again I live in Atlanta but
that's in Georgia Georgia is a radically
different place from Atlanta and if I'm
driving right off Georgia's North
Florida I have a concealed weapons
license there's not a time that I don't
have a weapon
right I think it the gun conversation I
don't know that people recognize the
extent to which the NRA is in chaos
right now yeah yeah I've been covering
conservative movement politics for years
and I have never seen people in the
broader pro-gun community as pissed off
and as interested in complaining to
reporters about the way the NRA is
operating the way it's spending donor
money then they have been in the last
six months it's really crazy it turned
out the NRA it's pretty swampy yes you
strapped right now Mike huh let's drop
right now now I'm in California I
couldn't admit if I was right I got Mike
what did you think of cardi B's summit
with Bernie Sanders then Venice I would
get so encouraged because this is the
country that prompt well this is a
country of vagrants unone it's and
protesters in our inception we're
essentially the Luud of the United
Kingdom but car D represents the young
heir for Latino woman from from poor and
working-class background who has now
used her platform when she could have
become far more conservative made her
money and walked away she used it to
engage not only for her own
self-interest but the self-interest on
behalf for people
she's now probably in a forty thirty
five to forty five percent tax bracket
and she said I don't mind paying my
money I just would like my money to go
other places besides Miller's here I'd
like you to go in education and I think
that's what my grandparents wanted when
they moved from the deep south that's
what your parents want so for me seeing
her participate in it invigorates me
because I know other young women 18 19
21 years old who may not be going to
college for four and six year degrees
but maybe going to beauty school maybe
working menial jobs
it makes them well that's an interesting
point then because Ernie who you support
yes okay he's for free college yeah I've
raised this point before why should
people who don't go to college be
subsidizing the ones who do because the
people who go to college you're going to
making a lot more money College is not
free
somebody's going to be paying for that
college I don't understand why the
people who get the benefit of it
shouldn't be paying for college and
trade school and this is from a dad who
has had children who went to both my
oldest son went to I'm a tech trade and
learned computer engineering and things
of that nature and sound engineer and my
daughter's did two years he didn't same
two years twice I'm in Savannah State
but he offered college and trade school
part of being an American is being a
steward for the next generation of
Americans my grandparents worked in
fields my grandmother went to college my
grandfather toiled on a blue-collar job
so that my sisters and I could then have
post-secondary education I don't mind as
an American now investing in the greater
America if we're going to build an
infrastructure you got to have carpet in
there
[Applause]
rick wilson would bringing the troops
back from afghanistan give trump enough
political capital to win in 2020 I
haven't heard that race know what it's
going to do is provide video of the
Taliban cutting women's heads off right
and stoning women to death always
returning to a state of medieval
savagery it's making it but once boycott
Israel pianist and great again because
that's where the real Nazis are I would
like to yes and matters of talking about
immigration you know there's a group of
philosophy Jews out of Eastern Africa
that are that are in Israel tonight and
I would like to say and I talk about
Israel let's not forget there there's a
Palestinian group of people living there
and that conflict is there and we know
about it many of us have Jewish and
Palestinian friends as American it's
something that you constantly balancing
but let's not forget that there's what
they call Veda Israel or the eastern
African Jews that are there and they
also are not treated the best by
government and we should be in our
relation and our growth of our
relationship with in Israel be
encouraging because there was in the
seven nine years ago women were being
given in vitro and not given the full
spectrum of the dangers and things that
are going on and say so let's make sure
that in our talks with Israel that we
don't leave out that there's a bigger
yes because it's government it's not
about a big exodus from Ethiopia so they
connected in some way the rust is what
the Rastafarian yeah but its debts
Christianity like the old Christian
Bible is in Ethiopia but prior to
European so why do they Rogers worship
this Ethiopian Emperor why do why people
worship a Caesar and it looks like a
beach bum
I don't know Abrahamic religions started
in that mr. horn in Africa so it affects
people differently but let's just not
forget that there's an old thousands of
year old group of Jewish people call for
lattes that are in Israel too and they
need to be treated with love and respect
okay thank you everybody
to see you next time
you